[Music]
all right welcome everyone to
grandmaster's Choice today I Am Woman
grandmas Talia cantes and the topic that
I wanted for today is what it means to
commit to a move um in the sense that
maybe you're at times you know playing a
game in which you're not sure whether
it's the right moment or not to commit
to a sacrifice you have to first you
know get some intuition some feeling for
it then you have to calculate everything
out you're not sure there are nerves so
this hopefully will work as kind of a
kind of an aid
to to
um go through the game of chess and
sacrifices and I have planned two
examples today the first one is kind of
the successful kind
uh what happens you know when you
properly calculate out a sacrifice so
maybe some people are familiar with this
position especially after Queen 28 um it
is a very famous example from a game
between Gary kaspar and anatol Caro from
uh 1990 right and maybe some of you are
familiar because there is a there is a
very well um wellmade interview for SP
of in which he describes his thought
process during this
game so I kind of just want to start by
evaluating this position kind of asking
what's your what's your natural instinct
what would you do here with the white
pieces who do you think is better why um
kind of like a quick overview to get a
feel for the for the
position what do you think like if you
were playing here would you rather be
white or black okay and why and what
would you
do how
come I guess if there's no attack then
it could be very scary
with
yeah for sure you have to count on the
attack here right um I feel like it
could maybe get a little bit scary for
for white uh with some pressure on the E
file and as you said the past C Pawn
that black has but at the same time we
do have the two Bishops and if you think
about it not only do we have the two
Bishops but all of our pieces are well
placed right like our Knight on G4 is on
the king side our other Knight is also
on the king side uh you know on the
center they're looking towards the king
side this Rook right here has some
potential maybe on the G7 square with
the help of this B2 Bishop uh this Rook
on the E file you know it there can be
some tactics in the future involving
that this queen can get into the game in
the future where it is you know um in
this diagonal or another way
so for sure it does look like whites
pieces are well placed the question is
how how can we execute um
um how can we execute a threat
here okay so you want to play Knight H6
without much thought because it just
looks right it just looks yeah yeah
that's kind of what Kasparov said too he
just he mentioned that you know he
looked at Knight H6 he calculated a few
lines and then he realized okay this
looks good enough and then he plays
Knight H6 and while kov is thinking he's
um unraveling all of the different
variations
right so like I was mentioning earlier a
lot of the white pieces are already
placed right and they look like they're
ready to start an attack on the king
side and and the reason why this Knight
takes H6 move even though it looks so
out of nowhere uh makes so much sense at
the same time is because white
definitely has more attackers looking
into the king side that black has
Defenders right um so in this position
Knight takes H6 did you guys consider
this move
maybe
no it's kind of a yeah it's a very out
there
it's a very out there move but like you
know we're always looking for checks
captures and threats right so even if it
looks a little bit silly Knight takes H6
as a move that that we need to consider
um and as we were saying so the G7 Pawn
is pinned so if if um if kpov is going
to to recapture in this position or
accept the sacrifice and it has to be
with this Rook right Rook takes
H6 this is not the move that happened in
the game but we're going to talk about
all of the different complications that
happen from from this move right and as
we were saying since the Rook is no
longer on the E file we have potential
for discovered discovered threats with
Knight takes
D6 uh it might not be easy at first to
calculate everything up but it is very
beautiful all of the different
continuations that that happen for
example let's say queen D7 probably the
the
one of the least challenging responses
that black
has how can we keep going right
and this kind of brings it back to my
points of today about committing to a
move once you play Knight takes H6 there
is no way back right like you are
already in a position where you
sacrifice the Knight you are trying to
prove that you have enough attack enough
uh compensation for the piece that
you're going to basically either
Checkmate your opponent or get all of
the material back right so you're in
that position to to prove things now and
that's where you m mix your original
intuition with calculation so now it's
your time to to prove why something like
this would be would be
good so Queen to D7 how can we keep
adding pressure and bringing pie
bringing pieces into the attack because
it is sure that we have uh you know some
attack on G7 but for now black is
defending quite well uh so what can we
do uh I think not of
five does make sense because you're
putting pressure on this
too um
let's see what could
be what could be a
problem maybe just Rook
H Rook H7 which looks a little weird but
somehow everything is
defended the Knight on the Knight on
D6 is is not necessarily bad place right
obviously it's under a lot of attack
with the bishop and the queen but at the
same time
um if we keep making threats and if we
keep going with tactical ideas this KN
can become really dangerous on D6 okay
so Rook
G6 Rook
G6 okay so you want to do like takes
takes and then Queen H5 or just it takes
Queen
H5 oh of course
yeah
um
okay let's see maybe I have
time I'm not sure but maybe I have time
to play C3 and block this bishop yeah
the reason
I I could take on C3 then you could
uhhuh yeah yeah I mean if you
play
mhm
like a move in this position or
before I'm just looking you play if you
play you play C3
there Bishop white still
H6 right and then after Pawn takes you
have Queen to4
Che well yeah good thing is that I have
Bishop G7
now and then this is still a a
problem there is a much more creative
move that um Kasparov has in this
position actually and again it kind of
involves the the basic principles of
chess with some high level calculation
right which means
that we already have enough pieces in
the attack but we need to make sure that
we always keep making making threats and
adding on attackers one piece that is
not part of the attack right now is this
queen right and we need to get her
involved
somehow Queen D4
D2 ah queen queen D2 or queen
D4 that is
true at the same time you also have to
consider like capturing here on on D6 so
like for example Queen D2 let's say I
think there's enough time
to
take and same with Queen
C8 um or maybe take with the queen too
Queen
D4 Queen
D4
C3 that is true there is um there is C3
uh I can't take here because of Queen H4
but um I can try to block this diagonal
for sure we don't want to give our
opponent time to to try and counteract
our threats there is a really U really
powerful move in this position Queen to
G4 and you might be wondering well why
would I ever want to trade
queens in a position where I'm attacking
and you know I'm also I just also
sacrifice the knif so it doesn't really
make sense to trade Queens but there is
a deeper idea behind it right the queen
is coming to G4 with an extra threat
here on on G7 um so this queen has no
time to take here on D6 and at the same
time
um at the same time this queen on D7 has
to do something right because it's under
attack so what happens after Queen takes
G4 right so there is an intermediate
move Knight F7 take taking back on on G4
wouldn't really do anything and you end
up losing the Knight on on D6 but that's
the that's the key idea there is this
knight of7 move very tricky and after
King
G8 there is actually a very beautiful
sequence with Knight H6 Pawn takes Rook
takes G4 and it is true that the Queens
are off the board but it doesn't mean
that Black's problems have gone away
right so King's forced to go to F7 then
Bishop G6 King G8 um and you can have
many discover checks with the bishop I
guess but the most effective is Bishop
to F5 King F7 Bishop B6 it's beautiful
how the two Bishops keep working
together right this King will never find
a a safe spot the king can go to E7 or
E8 but then we have Bishop D5 King moves
again and Bishop takes B7 and white
manages to get into an end game uh with
a rook up and the position is uh
completely uh completely winning so
there's this really beautiful move Queen
to G4 very nice idea uh with the
intermediate check of Knight
F7 um so that's what happens if queen to
queen to G4 uh sorry if Queen D7 Queen
G4 uh there's also another response with
Queen to H5 maybe trying to trade of
Queens on on um on Black's
terms but there's another another really
strong move here that white can do and
it has to do with distraction we want to
distract this queen as much as we can
can and at the end of the day Queen to
H5 doesn't really pose any threat
because if Queen takes D1 we still have
the knight of7 move
right so how can we keep making threats
as white and improve our
position
and like I said there is a really famous
interview of kaspar uh going over going
over this game and explaining his
thought process and it's just very
beautiful to see because you can tell
that the guy uh loves chess just by the
way that he obviously you know he was a
world champion perhaps best player ever
so clearly he had to love chess but it's
he's very expressive during this
interview and he shows a lot of um a lot
of funest for all of the variations that
he talks about this one included
so why could be a really strong move
here for for
white
and like I said there's no way back
because you already started the
sacrifices so by this point you can you
know you can give up your whole house
all of your pieces as long as the
threats keep coming so okay how about
Rook
G5 Rook G5 this is actually the
strongest move and it's really really
beautiful right
because so many pieces are hanging in
this position right uh the Knight on D6
The Rook on G5 the queen on D1 there can
be so many captures and Rook to G5 is a
very very nice way to to continue
because like we said if Queen takes D1
then there's nothing to worry about
there's the same Knight
of7 and Knight
takes um and there's no no actual
challenge in the position King to h8
Rook takes D1 and then maybe the only
inconvenience here would be C3
uh since we're getting into an end game
where white is happen exchange but this
Pawn on C3 is very dangerous however
there is still a the fact that the
Queens are off the board this is
something very important to keep in mind
in general the fact that the Queens are
off the board doesn't necessarily mean
that there's no danger to a King right
and in this particular case uh Black's
King is still in danger there is one
winning continuation one winning idea
here and then it slides
out
especially when the when the when the
material is being traded down or you
have a material
advantage um or you're getting into an
end game
even you always want to make sure that
you keep the initiative right that you
keep threats in the position the fact
that pieces are coming off the board
doesn't necessarily mean that that the
position is dull right and this is a
great example of
that so what about Knight to F to F7
right Knight F7 and then the King has to
go to G8 Bishop to G6 yeah Bishop G6 and
then all of a sudden black is in a lot
of trouble if C takes B2 Rook H5 and
there's no no way to stop Rook h8 right
um the king is simply stuck all of the
and if you think about it like all of
the a lot of the the black pieces are on
the on the queen side right on the
complete opposite side of the board
doesn't matter that they have so many
pieces they're not really doing anything
to help out this King right so that's
something very important to always keep
in mind as well when you're developing
an attack and you're not sure if it's
working if it's not working if the
sacrifice is going to to bring a win or
not um always keep in mind you know once
you cut the board in half how many
pieces are on the side where the
opponent's king is right um if they have
enough Defenders enough pieces on that
side ready to to go and take care of the
threats then that's great if they don't
then you know that it's going to take uh
a long time for the opponent to bring
all of their pieces to to the aid of the
King
right and this is a good example of that
none of the none of the black pieces can
help out so
this is a very beautiful
variation um and like I said kaspar was
kind of unraveling all of the lines as
as it was carpo moves
and the the whole sacrifice in general
is extremely beautiful um not just this
particular line so after Knight takes D6
there is one last variation that I want
to go over which is Queen takes E1 what
happens if black decides to give up the
queen uh to try and minimize some of the
danger get enough material for the
queen um and get rid of the main
attackers however this is not really the
case um the attack cannot be slowed down
Queen takes
E1 and then after Rook takes D6 because
the bishop cannot move it's do defending
G7 there's Queen to E4 and after Knight
D3 there's a very beautiful take Stakes
Queen to H4 King to G8 and again this is
going to be another key example of what
it means to have a lot of pieces but
none of them being able to help Bishop
takes G7 another sacrifice King G7 and
queen to G4 and it is impressive but no
piece can defend G7 right uh there's no
Rook A7 trying to to defend from the
from far away in the file there's no
Rook D7 because of Queen takes D7 this
Knight this bishop there's no way that
they can help uh it's incredible but
black doesn't have any piece that can
help their King right it's just so
lonely on one side of the board the fact
that there is a pent the3 doesn't mean
anything because the king is going to
get miden so this is completely winning
for white as it is impossible to defend
G7 so yeah like I said these examples
bring a lot of the the very basic
principles of Chess right like always
make sure that your king is well
protected have your pieces
coordinated um
and if you're on the attacking side then
of course you want to make sure that you
have more attackers and defenders in a
position you want to make sure that your
heavy pieces are in the attack right um
you want to open up the the the files
where the opponent's king is right all
of the all of the very basic concepts
but we see them uh being executed in a
very masterful way right um and this is
caspy we talking about right so the guy
is basically a
machine
so this is kind of what happens if if uh
kpov decides to accept the the sacrifice
with Rook takes um H6 however in the
game probably he was going through all
of these different lines decided not to
take on H6 but at least try to pose some
challenges to the to the white position
instead of handing the the the the
initiative straight into White's hands
and he decided to play with
C3
uh he decided to play with uh with C3 in
this
position uh but thankfully white has
enough time to to take care of all of
the all of the threats he actually
decided to play Knight to F5 just bring
the Knight back C takes B2 and now Queen
to
G4 the pressure keeps on coming there's
a there's a lot of pieces attacking here
on G7 uh there are ideas for example of
Queen H4 and Knight G5 obviously you
have to deal with this but it's not a
it's not a huge problem the bishop even
though the knights are in the way the
bishop's still looking into into the
long diagonal and like I said a lot of
the a lot of the black pieces are on the
opposite side of the board so it's
really hard for them to to get to the
defense of the King on
time Bishop to C8 is a move that that
was played by kpo and after Queen to H4
Rook to H6 trying to at least give up
some material to the F uh for example if
King to G8 there is a very beautiful
move here that white can do just to get
rid of any threats before they decide to
go for
checkm
also we have a comment in the chat
referencing my gaming as nepo today from
title
Tuesday uh today is one of the best days
ever I'm very happy because I happen to
play yanon title Tuesday in round one
and I made a draw I was playing from my
classroom philosophy
class um I was playing with my touchpad
I didn't have I didn't have my mouse or
anything and to be fair I didn't my
accuracy wasn't very high but still a
draw is a draw and it's been a very
happy day I've been smiling all day it's
uh yeah let's not jinx it of course but
it's a it's a good day so
yeah my game was too bad so I couldn't
show it today uh it was a there were a
lot of inaccuracy so that couldn't have
been my topic but um but
yeah
I'm sure kasp is a better example than I
am so
I King H2 yeah what a what a silly
little move but at the same time so
strong um the idea is simply Knight G5
there's no way to stop it as long as you
play Knight G5 and Rook takes C1 doesn't
come with a
check um it's it's ideal right
so King H2 simply prophylaxis
and now there's nothing that black can
do right Knight G5 is coming Checkmate
is coming Rook takes E1 doesn't doesn't
have a check so G6 maybe can be a try
but after Knight to G5 uh there are too
many threats going on right like Rook A7
for example but after Knight takes
Bishop takes Knight H6 the position is
just collapsing
completely again too many pieces on the
other side there's opponent B2 but it's
nowhere near promoting
right so that's what happens if King to
G8 maybe that's why uh kpov decided to
play Rook to
H6 thinking that maybe after Knight
takes H6 sorry after Knight takes H6 PA
takes um somehow there's no immediate
threat right sometimes uh when defending
you can really give your opponent the
possibility of getting back some of the
material as long as you get rid of all
of the threats and then with the
remaining extra material that you have
you win the game but in this position
the threats never stop right um however
we have to do something about
this and just to make sure that um all
of our pieces on the next turn are ready
for for an attack and completely
destroying the black position once again
we have this King H2 just so that when
we move the Knight there is no Queen
takes E1 with
check um and the game is is pretty much
one already Queen to E5 Knight to G5
very serious threats it's almost
impossible to stop everything at the
same time there's Knight F7 uh there is
pressure here um H6 is always a problem
the idea of Queen E4 in some positions
to get into H7 uh the position is just
way too open the fact that the bishop
went back to C8 doesn't help because it
also caused some
coordination but um there's 's no way
that black can defend everything at the
same time Queen to F6 was played Rook to
E8 again thanks to to uh the lack of
coordination that black
has Bishop to F5 trying to ease the
position a little bit if Rook takes A8
maybe bishop takes B1 you get rid of the
bigger threats and then this Pawn does
become a a problem but here once again
Kasparov plays like Kasparov and gives
us a beautiful combination
Knight of seven so Knight of seven and
then after Queen takes H6 Queen H6 I
think I am well Bishop
H7
maybe I'm not on time to play Bishop
H7 because it
takes wait no I am on time I think yeah
play takes and
then maybe maybe maybe it works
thankfully after the bishop moves I have
this
so
uh there might be Rook G8 but then for
sure um for sure black has enough pieces
for the
queen you're close you're close
though maybe wrong move
order
Queen H6 right what a yeah what a again
what a what a beautiful move right like
The Rook on on E8 prevents the Bishop
from taking the only option is to
recapture with this queen but this queen
on F6 is very overworked right um a lot
of times obviously this is a very
particular case but a lot of times uh we
talk about how the queen is an active
piece right it doesn't really serve the
role of of protecting things uh the good
thing is that it can it can be used to
to defend the position um in a lot of
different angles but we can also use
that in our advantage right and in this
case we're using the fact that the queen
on F6 is overworked um to distract it
and then take uh take control of one of
the squares it stops defending right
with Knight to
F7 it's a very beautiful Fork but we're
not focused on getting the queen back we
actually have Bishop takes F5 right and
this is how the game continued uh again
clear example of white having less
pieces than black but what matters is
how beautifully coordinated they are
right um for for the whole time that we
have been looking at this game The Rook
on A8 hasn't done much neither have the
Knight on D5 or B5 or B4 and the two
Bishops even though we sacrified the
dark Square Bishop have pretty much
sealed the game in White's favor
the only move here is Queen to
G6 and Gary decided to take with the
bishop he actually Express a lot of
regret in not taking with the Rook on G6
because it's pretty much light out here
um The Rook is going to move somewhere
along the along the G file in the next
move and it's going to be Checkmate as
you know the Rook bishop and Knight
control all of the squares so something
like this is not possible it's simply
because the Rook goes
back
um but Bishop takes G6 as was playing in
the game is also completely
winning uh King to G7 and then after a
few moves Rook takes A8 thankfully the
B1 square is covered Bishop to E7 Rook
B8 Bishop D5 takes Bishop uh Bishop B4
takes Bishop D5 and after Knight takes
D5 Rook takes B2 is coming so um here
actually Kaio decided to resign
and essentially what happens was that
even though kpov had so much material
because of the attack he had to give
everything away right or like everything
was captured along the way which is very
um I guess I don't know I find it
humorous but it kind of shows the the
strength of an attack right and even
from this position right
here that looked maybe un
assuming um
kasp definitely tuned into his you know
uh
intuition uh maybe his Skiller Instinct
something was telling him that there was
a there was some sort of uh some sort of
combination here right some promising
variation and again it all ties back to
the fact that white has all of their
pieces looking into the looking into the
kingside ready for anything that that
can happen uh meanwhile well black
pieces will take a long time to even get
involved
right any questions about this
example again just pretty much showing
the the beauty of um of Caspar's play
right and then a lot of times you're
looking at games like this games from uh
world champions and you're thinking wow
it's such a beautiful such a beautiful
flow like all of the moves makes so much
sense when the world champions do
it the you know the ideas just keep on
flowing I get so inspired that's great I
want to play like them but um
unfortunately reality is a little bit
harsher and playing like aspy of can be
can be very very difficult and that's
what I want to get on uh to with the
next game so we just saw how Kasparov
executed a very wonderful attack the
move Knight takes H6 was more int
intuitive than you know pure
calculation now we have a similar
example this position right here after
Queen to B7 this is actually a game of
mine from 2022 I've briefly shown this
example before I don't know if I've done
that on the stream uh but it's from the
2022 US Women's Championship this was a
very very good tournament for me um and
this game you know gave me some
confidence as
well um and we have a right to to this
position in the game I feel very happy
with my with my current position with
the white
pieces uh we
can take once again like a quick look to
to analyze and um
evaluate evaluate what's going on so
what do you guys think would would you
rather play with the white pieces with
the black
pieces
um why what move would you play in this
position you were white I was playing
with the white piece
play well you're
right I mean again you know you've got
you've got all white species except the
except the
King
right it's almost done yeah there are so
many ideas that can arise from this
position right and again if you divide
the boarding half uh you have the queen
on B7 which is relatively far away from
the action on the king sign the bishop
on C5 might not be able to to be a
Defender this Rook on A8 uh this Rook on
f8 maybe works as a as a blockade
actually preventing the king from from
escaping so um certainly it feels like
there is something here so if you just
had to make a move in the next 10
seconds what would you play here as
white Bop H6 yeah without even thinking
about it right Bishop takes H6 it makes
so much sense
um
so when the position happened over the
board I was just thinking okay how does
it how does it not work Bishop H6 it
just makes so much sense um I was about
to play it like within 5 minutes of of
my opponent making her move and then the
more I thought about Bishop H6 the more
I started calculating variations I
couldn't find a clear a clear path um
and then that led me to a rabbit hole of
thinking for 30
minutes and then eventually I decided
not to play Bishop takes H6 but it just
again it just looks so natural right
like it just looks like it should work
but I was afraid of committing to Bishop
H6 because I just could not calculate
everything out so I think we're going to
start off with this with this move
because it's just what makes the most
sense Bishop H6 right of course uh black
has to take there's no other way to go
right so what can we do
here Rook takes H6 uh Rook takes H6 the
idea is to attack this Knight and
potentially threaten um H7 at the same
time however there is a very interesting
move move here that that black has which
is Queen to
E4 and it poses a lot of it poses a lot
of challenges because it's offering a
queen trade E5 is hanging you don't have
time to capture here on F6 it's actually
a little bit
dangerous so this was actually a move
that that I was um quite concerned about
because for example if Rook takes a oops
well I just show a move if Rook takes H6
um let's say like Bishop to to E7 then
Knight to G4 is actually very strong and
I don't think there's a clear way to to
get out of this as black but if uh Queen
to E4 then you know there are a lot more
challenges
for um for
white another idea that I had in this
position which I guess we can start off
with is either Queen D2 or queen C1 this
was another very basic uh basic idea
it's a very common theme instead of The
Rook on H6 you would want the queen
right so you can try to bring the queen
over uh Queen to let's say queen
to queen to
D2 let's say queen queen C1 just to make
it pretty Queen C1 this was my original
idea I think both of them are equivalent
to one
another um so I want to get my queen on
H6 and I want to checkm on h8 it's very
simple also if I get my queen to H6 I
have this idea of Rook G3 and it pretty
much looks um Unstoppable
right however there is this move Knight
to H7 and then the only move that I
considered in this position was Queen
takes H6 because it just looks very
natural and the more I analyze this
variation the more confused I got right
because again looks like it's so close
to working but I could I could not um
confirm it with like pure calculation so
if
F6 uh which is the most natural way to
continue Rook to G3 again makes a lot of
sense King to h8 Knight
G6 uh Knight
to Knight to G5 and then in my head I
was thinking you know H4 I'm going to
get my piece back uh but at the same
time black can get rid of any of the
threats
after
um yeah black can get rid of all of the
threats after the move Queen H7 and the
thing is
that there's no again there's no no way
for me to escape with my queen so I'm
forced to I'm forced to
take and then this I was thinking about
it in my head
um what's that like moves in I was
thinking about this position in my head
and I was like well you know it's just
an end game like I'm not better here uh
the position is about equal and I was a
little bit concerned with like my knight
on E5 because it has to move point on H6
is hanging so I just did not really
think that it was a you know that I
needed to put in all of my effort to to
get this this Payback right um
so is this what you guys were going
considering because I feel like all of
the moves that I was playing with white
make a lot of sense uh like Queen T H6
makes a lot of sense however it's
actually um an incorrect
move it's actually an incorrect move um
but like I said you know Queen C1 Queen
H6 that was my original idea I thought
about this position for a long time I
also thought about Rook cage six as we
were talking I was trying to come up
with so many many different ways of
making this sacrifice work and then
sometimes I was thinking okay I found
the right variation and then I would
find a reputation for black and
sometimes you're just sitting in front
of a board and then you don't realize
that you just spend 30 minutes right
because there is just like so much
richness in a in a position then you
just um get a little bit too too into
it uh we try to play like Kasparov but
then reality reality hits us
right um so actually there's a very very
cool idea uh Queen C1 and queen D2 are
still winning but they only win when you
mix it with a different with a different
idea which is the move that I
accidentally showed uh which is B4 right
and you might be thinking what is B4
this has nothing to do with anything I
actually did not consider this move in
this position but the idea I did see I
was trying to play around with it but
somehow I just didn't you know mix the
two plans together but B4 is very
interesting because before we jump right
into the threat we want to make sure
that all of the opponent's pieces are as
uncoordinated as possible we want to
completely disrupt um we want to
completely disrupt any coordination that
the pieces had make sure that they are
in squares where they can fall off right
where they're not protected where
they're weak and at the same time B4
opens a very important
diagonal so we're going to see what
happens first of all if Bishop takes B4
because it's the most natural uh natural
move here Queen to C1 still going for
the for the ideas on on H6 Knight to H7
just like we saw uh but now Rook to G3
is very
important uh Knight to G5 doesn't really
uh do anything you can even play H4
probably you can sacrifice as well but
just
H4 King to h8 and now is when the idea
of B4 comes to light what can we do now
yeah Queen to B2 Queen to H6
unfortunately doesn't work um because of
Rook
G8 but Queen to B2 and there's really no
way to stop all of the threats right
there's this um discover check idea with
Knight F7 or Knight G6 Knight F7 a
little bit better of course but still uh
there's this discovery idea
the we have we're attacking the the
bishop on B4 right which is loose it
doesn't have
any um it doesn't have any uh any
Defender like as opposed to when it was
on C5 right and you know we're using the
fact again if you just look at this
position um like from above of like you
know just look look at this position
from outside the the game itself all of
the black pieces are really awkwardly
placed right um so the two Rooks are not
doing much the bishop is randomly here
on B4 there's a knight on
H7 Queen on B7 can't contribute to
anything because she's also on light
squares so it's hard to even um protect
the the diagonal or anything the bishop
is on the opposite side of the board if
Bishop was on F6 then uh black would be
would be fine but there's really no no
defense here anymore for for for
black um you can maybe try to play F6 if
you want to but then Knight G6 takes
with check so you're forced to take with
the King and then Queen takes B4 right
um utilizing the fact that again all of
the pieces were very
loose so the only way to win with this
bishop takes H6 sacrifice is if you
combine those two
ideas so what happens if we don't play
Bishop takes B4 uh if black doesn't play
Bishop takes B4 Bishop to D6 is another
move uh and then it's still not very
easy to to figure out what to
do uh Queen to C1 is the best
continuation if Knight H7 then the
position just collapses there's Queen
takes H6 and too much going on F6 Rook
G3 and then this is uh
deadly but Bishop takes e E5 is kind of
the
main uh main continuation again black is
just taking everything uh Queen takes H6
and very strong move Knight to H5 to at
least disrupt the file for one more turn
Queen takes H5 F5 and at least you have
the bishop covering h8 sorry Bishop
covering h8 and then the queen covering
along the the seventh rank right somehow
it almost looked
like black actually manage to to defend
and get their pieces involved but there
is only one winning move here for
white and if you if you pay attention to
the position this move suddenly becomes
very
natural F4 F4 does make sense but it
does give a turn to Black to play
something like Bishop to D4 right and if
there is a check then the King has to
move and then maybe in the next turn
they can
um they can start defending somehow
maybe like Rook
F7 it's not so
clear we can do the threat in a
different
way
how many people here know that us your
Nao today well
thanks
um but yeah actually uh good suggestion
in the chat Rook to E1 and this makes a
lot of sense right because the one piece
that wasn't part of the game is all of a
sudden getting involved right it's
putting pressure onto this bishop the
pawn on E6 is hanging behind it and then
you even have ideas of Rook E3 Rook G3
right so uh
this you know again on principle it
makes sense you just need to back it up
with calculation which is the hard part
but a lot of times we just say that if
the move is
pretty uh you know it probably probably
works at the same time ugly moves they
tend not to work uh but obviously
everything needs to be calculated Rook
to E1 and then for example if something
like Bishop G7 then there's no way to
escape all of the threats Queen H7 uh
King F7 Rook G3 Rook G8 and queen G6 and
then the pawn on E6 is hanging uh
everything is
collapsing
so again if the bishop goes to to F6 to
try and cover um you do have Rook takes
E6 I'm pretty sure that's winning you
also have Rook E3 I guess with this idea
um I I assume that this is winning for
sure uh because there is just no way
that this king is ever going to find
shelter right like all the pawns are
gone the king is not escaping to the
other side of the for the position is
just
collapsing so this is what happens if
Bishop D6 and then lastly if Bishop to
uh Bishop to
E7 then all of a sudden there is no no
longer a control that the queen can have
on the seventh rank so after Queen to C1
similar to the line that I showed at
first Knight H7 Queen takes H6 and then
there's no longer the F6 that we were
seeing right like F6 Rook G3 Knight G5
H4 Queen H7 remember we're talking about
that line well it doesn't it doesn't
exist anymore because there's no
coordination right so it's impressive
but either you know either the bishop
goes to a war square or we can capture
it because it goes to a square that it
can't be defended or it completely
disrupts any connection um that the
black pieces have to try and defend
right so this move B4 all of a sudden is
very very um
um very disruptive to to the black
position it is the move that I missed I
briefly like I said I briefly saw the
idea but somehow it wasn't able to
connect all of the all of the
strings but again it just goes on to
show right like sometimes you have good
intuition you know that a move is going
to work what matters is to calculate
everything out right if you're able to
do it then congratulations you can
um you can go ahead and do your
sacrifice sometimes it's a little bit
harder than that this is a more human
example of when it's hard to commit to a
move because if you play Bishop H6
there's no way back right like uh if you
decide to to make a sacrifice then you
really have to prove afterwards with
your moves that there is a that there is
something and in this particular case I
just wasn't able to calculate everything
out but at the same time hey this is
this is why in chess we're so so adamant
about working on tactics and
calculations solving puzzles improving
your killing your Killer Instincts your
intuition all of that right um like how
sharp you are how fast you can see moves
how to control nerves everything so yeah
this was a very nice idea just to
briefly show in the game I didn't go for
it but what ended up happening was very
funny uh I decided to play Queen to C1
first after drinking for a long time
this move is like about equal it doesn't
bring the same power that Bishop takes
H6
did uh but after Queen to C1 my opponent
played H5 which is very unexpected move
I was expecting something like Knight to
E4 um and then there are some
complications but black is fine and my
opponent played H5 and I was like okay
well H5 doesn't really improve Black's
position in any
way uh um so I'll play Bishop H6
now and it's a very strange idea because
Bishop H6 no longer takes a pawn it's
just very strange move at least I am
threatening Rook to G3 that was my plan
or even Bishop to
G7 um but this this tournament was also
broadcasted with you know live
commentary from very strong chess
players so I was just thinking wow what
are they saying about my
game because um I didn't play Bishop H6
but I do it like two most later um
and yeah the game actually ended up
ended up being um good for me either way
uh I just want to showcase if Bishop if
G takes H6 Queen takes and there's no
way to stop all of the all of the
different
threats um but my opponent played Knight
to E4 which is the the best move in the
position Rook takes H5 F6 Knight to
G4 um thankfully if takes I have Knight
takes
H6 and again the position is kind of
collapsing King G7 there's this very
strong Knight to F5 takes Queen H6 and
then after a few checks I managed to
skew the queen very
beautiful again lack of coordination
that's what happens Queen F7 though is
what my opponent played Rook H4 and here
Queen G6 was
important uh after Queen G6 Bishop B3 uh
rook ad8 and then here we just play a
normal position black is down the pawn
but all of a sudden my Rook on H4 is
very awkward because I no longer have an
attack right I have to start retreating
my pieces it's kind of imbalanced very
unclear but computer says about
equal however here my opponent played
rook fd8 and again the position is very
difficult to to hold because we're both
also getting into time trouble uh but
just to close it off um again I'm not
going to miss a second chance right
Bishop
G7 um Bishop G7 and then the thing is
that if the king decides to take Queen
H6 and queen h8 is
Checkmate and if Queen takes G7 Knight
to H6 King to f8 King is forced to run
away Rook takes E4 right and again this
king is not going to find any shelter um
I have broken through the defenses my on
H6 is completely fine it can always go
to G uh G4 if it needs to um and then I
also have a very deadly threat the game
uh went on with E5 Rook
G4 Queen H7 Rook G8 and then after King
E7 I have the very beautiful Rook
G7 with the idea that after takes which
is kind of the only move Knight to F5
and a fork right um this was kind of the
last uh you know
the last tactic of the game um after
this I was able to I think the game
obviously went on something like this
and then I was able to to uh transform
my advantage very easily in the end game
um especially because I
have uh some pass pawns as well on the
other side and the king is just so weak
I can control all the light squares with
my queen um it was a very smooth uh
conversion later on uh and I went on to
to win the
game but yeah so this is just I wanted
to show kind of like a side by-side
example from you know a a game where you
know white decides to commit to night
takes stage six go for go for sacrifices
and
then figure it out with
calculation uh work through it along the
way um although in reality you know it
can be it can be very difficult to
to like I said commit to commit to one
move uh and then again calculation is
needed sometimes there are nerves
involved and then you're not sure what
to go for in a
position um but as a closer remark I do
want to say if your intuition is telling
you to go for a move then you should go
for it um it also makes it very
difficult for the opponent to to defend
uh because practically it's easier to be
on on the attacking side right it's
easier to have the initiative than to be
the one defending because then you do
have to be very precise right um so
these were two I thought two interesting
examples Kasparov obviously um a genius
me I don't know about that
but um it's just
a an interesting side by side I thought
so with that I think we're kind of uh
closing for for today as long as there
are no more questions about these two
examples right uh then we're
good and I hope that you guys get the
courage now to to do all of your
beautiful sacrifices in your own games
yeah so yeah thank you so much for for
being here uh thanks to all of the
people that watch online are we ending
the stream are we going whenever you say
bye okay I guess we're ending byebye
thank you so thank you
[Music]
thank